[Musik]
der present sorry falls ich ein bisschen
fertig aussehen aber ich komme gerade
vom see wo wir waren bei super wetter
und dann kam auch gestern kein video und
das kommt jetzt heute und wir fangen wir
an zu zocken
ich habe ehrlich gesagt kein bock auf
diese ganzen sachen wir es gibt das
einfach mal ziel des ganzen spiels ist
es dass wir hier irgendwie ausbrechen
können deshalb wir fangen wir nehmen
natürlich jetzt erstmal die pfeile weil
das du das standard werkzeug ist wie man
sich das vorstellt
wir können euch direkt aus dem winter
raus oder direkt draußen das müsste er
eigentlich klar gehen denke ich okay was
viele nehmen aber wir gehen durch den
turbo ich hab vergessen zu klingen
you've got wie reflexes of that you can
die fenster stars by clicking blabla wie
wird erhört ausgesprochen hat also ich
weiß dass alarm heißt aber heißt es
alerta alerta ok cool aber ich kann
jetzt sagen riet reformstart oder
einfach normal ried 3
ich mache normal wie private jetzt komme
ich mich hier raus und ich muss jetzt
hier klicken
das weiß ich klicke dich schön danke
dass du mir das jetzt sagt werde ich
schaffe es jetzt und ich klicke und
jetzt folgt den golden tiger woods muss
okay ich bin im nächsten zimmer
das ist schon mal richtig geil ok
nämlich entweder im stuhl und die
granaten
ich nehme die granaten
das ist doch nicht wahr als auch die
granate einfach wieder eingerollt ist
dieser herr als ob ich mich einfach
immer für das falsche entscheide okay
ich habe mich jetzt mal für den stuhl
entschieden die richtung geht was ich
muss mich jetzt einmal richtig
entscheiden ich gehe nach links ok
zusammenfassung ich habe mich am anfang
falsch entschieden dann habe ich zwei
mal verkackt bei der komischen sache mit
dem mit der mit der stange da mit dem
boxen ist habe ich mich hierbei gerade
nochmal fatal dass es doch nicht wahr
oder schauen ob ich jetzt richtig mache
ich bin ein paar allerdings ich bin ein
fallschirm genau ich bin großer fan vom
fallschirmspringen und ich würde auch
fallschirmspringen über alle anderen
aktivitäten stellen und ich denke das
wird unser
[Musik]
ich weiß echt nicht was ich da sagen
soll
als auch nicht alles falsch mache also
laut der regel nach müsste das sei jetzt
richtig sein oder
[Musik]
ja wahrscheinlich kommen freunde wenn es
jetzt nicht das richtige ist landes oder
schmeißen die münze ich schmeiße ich
habe kein geld ich habe hier noch ein
ein euro stück das werden jetzt mal eben
dafür verwenden und zwar hier die seite
mit dem mit dem komischen tier ich glaub
besitzen vogel also die zahl steht für
die saugnäpfe und der adler steht für
das jetpack ich muss jetzt einfach mal
so hin und wir haben hier freunde wir
haben hier die zahl das war nochmal die
zahl
was war die zahl her bin ich behindert
ich hab's einfach schön da vergessen ich
glaube die zahl jedoch die zahl waren
die saugnäpfe das heißt sie wird die
saugnäpfe und wenn das nicht richtig ist
freunde dann ist aber hier mal was ganz
falsch mit einem
[Musik]
es hat geklappt
und fußball
diese münze rettet mir meine existenz
okay wir machen jetzt noch einmal von
vorne ich möchte nämlich einmal sehen
was mit dem teleporter passiert das mega
interessant ach ja wahrscheinlich
wahrscheinlich telefoniert er mich genau
dahin wo dieser typ steht und gerade
seine schusstechnik
was ist das denn
was macht ihr machen ich sage einfach
ich hatte eine schaufel geht euch
vergraben mit der schaufel die macht das
jetzt hoffe man okay ich bin schuldig
man freunde als großen abschluss für
dieses etwas andere spiel nehmen wir den
rocket launcher und schau mal was damit
passiert ach ja das ist nicht wahr und
wie wahr wie viel unglück hat dieser
kleine knabl naja freund ich hoffe euch
hat es gefallen so ein kleines spiel
heute für den mittwoch ich habe keine
ahnung ich bin wieder voll produzieren
oft so voll ist und ich mein leben lang
nur vorproduzieren ich bin meinen tag
hier und dann produziert wie videos oder
dann war ich wieder woanders weg und da
und blockt aber ich habe zurzeit von
sophos verlernen deswegen kommen in den
nächsten zwei drei wochen nur so kleine
games immer mal ab und zu
natürlich kommen zimmer am freitag und
so weiter und so fort lasten daumen hoch
da wenn es euch gefallen hat und dann
sehen wir uns wieder wenn ihr bock drauf
habt
[Musik]